[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared in the very pale
flesh again so we watch Netflix's new
Death Note movie this weekend and
thought it merited some discussion and
of course some spoilers if you watched
our video on the Death Note anime a
couple weeks ago you know that we're big
fans the show draws out incredibly
nuanced ideas about the nature of
justice justice justice justice justice
justice and even participates in its own
philosophical dialogue throughout the
series it's just damn good television
the movie well it's not exactly good
cinema now off the bat I just want to
say that adapting a 37 episode anime to
a single movie is really really hard
if someone hired me to do that I'd be
pumped my pants so we're not here to
grade how closely the new film sticks to
the anime or the manga it's an
adaptation and it deserves some room to
do its own thing so let's look at the
film on its own terms it's definitely
got some good things going for it
and the thing that I most admire is its
attempt to preserve some of the thematic
richness of the anime which is an
impressive goal for a 100 minute movie
that already packs in a lot action
sequences detective games gore and teen
romance from lights argument that his
systematic cheating is no big deal I'm
looking at homework here for at least 15
different students all right I get it
I'm in trouble all I'm trying to say is
you have the chance to stop the type of
people who make things hard for
everybody you've got to see the big
picture here - its conversation with his
dad at the end Death Note tries to put
some moral ambiguity into lights
character and gesture to bigger
questions about the nature of good and
evil given the time constraints he was
smart not to attempt the massive
discourses on justice that we see in the
anime but the film makes clear that it's
still interested in ethics just in a
simplified form but exactly can I do it
this dead no put a name
and see what happens unfortunately
that's where the film gets itself into
trouble toward the beginning mr Turner
tells light the guns as only as good as
his aim son I make sure people can trust
Aria here of course he's talking about
the role of the Seattle police but light
seems to adopt a similar principle using
the power the Death Note he liked his
anime counterpart wants to create a new
world where innocent civilians are
protected from the people who make life
miserable the Death Note is his gun and
that's the aim although he gets
squeamish about offing some law
enforcement we never really see light
compromising the intentions behind that
aim until his David Copperfield reveal
at the end of the film instead they
bring in a seductive power-hungry
girlfriend to play the role of bad cop
for 90% of the movie light is
unambiguously the good guy or at least
the kind of okay guy and that's a
problem Keira largely had the support of
the people including the police until
the death of the FBI team and who sent
eight federal agents walking off a
building the duplicitous Mia who stole
the notebook from light and wrote his
name in it
bad bad Mia who killed Watari by not
burning the page with his name on it
we're clearly supposed to blame me up
even though light put it there in the
first place although the film spends
next to no time developing what light
wants out of his new world he's still
shockingly quick to abandon it once
someone dies who hasn't committed a
felony or stolen someone's lunch money
do you really think people are gonna be
on their knees if you can talk to cure
like that we're not killing my dad Mia
this is over you just were not the good
guys anymore we aren't the good guys
anymore sounds a lot more like people
don't like us than an actual statement
about Kira's morality of rule and while
the third act of the film tries to play
up the difference between lights
reluctance to kill people and bad Mia's
bloodthirstiness
lights shift seems more pragmatic than
anything lights change of perspective
isn't an indication that there was ever
problems with his plan for becoming a
god just that the circumstances have
changed and he does
really want to go to prison but Mia
doesn't really mind if a gun is only as
good as its aim it seems like the film
should be asking questions about lights
aim with the Death Note but instead of
saying be careful of aiming your gun in
this direction it's more make sure your
crazy girlfriend doesn't get a hold of
your gun even Elle's quick personality
flip from I don't kill I just bring
justice to I might kill you in the same
way you killed hundreds of people seems
to be totally dependent on circumstance
the detective strong moral framework
developed since childhood gets tossed
away instantly when his friend goes
missing but there's no emphasis on the
significance of that change light ends
the film by telling his dad was simple
at first I was just gonna kill all the
bad guys and good guys would win but it
wasn't like that it's like you said
sometimes you gotta choose the lesser of
two evils but what are these two evils
my guess is that not even light knows
unlike the animate I know sorry I had to
say it death notes ethical ambiguity is
less about opening a multitude of
possibilities and more about shrugging
in the direction of good and evil while
ultimately saying nothing
you even says so interesting now once
again condensing an anime of that
magnitude into a relatively short film
is a difficult task and I won't begrudge
the filmmaker some reductions in depth
but what the story clone to most
questions about good and evil was poorly
executed and ended up hamstringing its
potential both philosophically and
dramatically anyway those are our
thoughts we're still experimenting with
this new quick-take format so if you
have thoughts on what we should cover
next let us know these guys if you're
looking for more wisecrack quick takes
on the latest stuff be sure to check out
our Rick and Morty podcast the Squatch
where we break down every single new
episode and you can find all this in the
description to catch y'all next time
[Music]
you